next on it is my great pleasure to
invite on stage Alex and Fonseca who is
the CEO of artiste Portugal in a
returning guest to our conference as
well as our president Ronan Cali to join
me here for a keynote chat with
Alexander Alexander last time we met one
year ago in Marseille you were the CTO
of Portugal telecom and since then you
have become the CEO of Altice Portugal
well first of all congratulations and
secondly could you please tell us about
your path what has happened over the
last year well first of all thank you
very much for the invitation true some
changes have happened in the last in the
last year I would say that it's been an
honor for me of course not only to lead
now the the biggest operation in
Portugal in telecom in telecom market
but most of it I would say that it's
relevant to say that the the path that
has been him that has been made has a
lot to do with the project that we have
outlined in 2015 when Altice acquired
Portugal telecom by the time we acquired
an incumbent it was the first time
Altice acquired an incumbent despite the
fact that we are already present in over
10 countries and the challenges were a
little bit different because having in
mind our strategy which is and remains
to get 100% fiber and there our
operations of course that as an
incumbent the challenges were I would
say in haste what happened in between
was exactly the fact that from the
technology space what we did was a huge
transformation and consolidation program
which not only I would say created a
more efficient environment in everything
that who went around technology and
operations but also by consolidating
we created a more agile company when I
say consolidation the work that I
started and now our new CEO is a villain
which will also be with you today is
continuing this path is to converge a
set of activities which sometimes are
totally apart but in the last I would
say ten years in terms of technology
have become more and more embedded in
between things like IT network
engineering network operations field
operations special operations even b2b
delivery areas are I would say have a
common point which is the need to be
effective in everything that regards the
operation itself so the consolidation
that we made that we started and we are
still deploying was exactly this this
enhancement of the way we do our
day-to-day business on the operation
side and this created not only a huge
saving in terms of cost but also created
a more agile company and I believe that
this was one of the reasons why the
changes that happen now have made a
person that comes from technology like
myself to lead the biggest player in
telecom space in Portugal thank you
looking at the Portuguese market perhaps
a little bit more broadly what do you
see as the latest developments obviously
it's a very advanced fiber market in
terms of deployment but I wonder whether
deployment availability and take-up of
fiber based services go hand-in-hand
what is your experience well it's true
that Portugal is in fact a very mature
market we are roughly I would say
between 5 to 6 million households
country and it's true that broadband has
been massively deployed in the urban
areas in the last few years so it's not
just it's not all fiber unfortunately
because we still have a huge footprint
not only often copper on DSL from
Portugal telecom but essentially there's
also a lot of cable covering the country
but it's true that I would say in the
last four or five years optical fiber
deployment has
and especially with the investments they
made first my Portugal telecom and all
by Altice Portugal nevertheless I would
say that our project remains one of the
biggest investments in the country we
have announced back in 2015 that we
wanted to cover I would say over 90
percent of the population with optical
fiber we would like to reach 5.3 million
households with optical fiber by 2020
this is of course an enormous challenge
in terms of investment in terms of
operation but a huge enhancement for the
country in the national economy as well
the good news is and I can tell you this
is public information that we have just
recently announced in the third quarter
last year that we went above the 4
million ohms past mark and we are now
over the 4.2 4.1 million homes bust
mark as we speak so I would say that
being able to deliver our in cruise
speed around 750 to 850 homes passed per
year is a tremendous challenge that we
proven to be possible and successful
this of course is something that for us
it's relevant not only for the
infrastructure of the country itself but
essentially as well because we believe
that the switchover from lower broadband
technologies like DSL and in some cases
even the cable industry towards fiber
it's clearly a differentiator towards
what people are looking for in terms of
usage and yes we've seen that tech take
apps of course I cannot provide the data
on that but we've seen that the take-up
rates are I would say in line with our
expectations at what I can tell you
Alexander clearly I'll tease Portugal
has such fantastic progress with regard
to the fibre to the home penetration so
far to date and certainly sounds like
the plans in place continue to to build
on those ambitions what canal tease
Portugal do uniquely to ensure that we
don't end up with a fibre divide
particularly for the rural communities
out there that's extremely important
because it's true that we have announced
a huge
project to fibre over 90% of the
population and we want that Portugal by
2020
to be one of the first European
countries to reach very close to 100
percent of the population covered with
fiber but this is important not only for
the challenge which is huge for the
investment which is huge but essentially
for one thing that we have put in our
minds from day one which is the
proximity concept proximity means that
being LT is Portugal being the
historical inheritance of an incumbent
we still believe that it's our
responsibility even on a social impact
responsibility perspective to give back
to the country some of the the
investments that we have done and the
growth that we have been experienced so
since day one we have created a part of
our program which is assigned to rural
municipalities this means that under our
program to fibre the country we are not
doing what others have done and are
still doing in Portugal which is to take
a look at only their big dense urban
areas as the commercial focus to deploy
fiber we are deploying fiber in
extremely rural areas in low density
areas where the pure business case is
not the only driver the driver is local
economy development is to fight the
certification of rural areas is to being
able to attract investment and create
jobs to fight unemployment as well so
this is something that we have put in
our own perspective in our own projects
and yes it's true that we do believe
that children that comes from the rural
areas have the same opportunities
regarding X access to IT -
infrastructure - communication
technologies they have the same right of
the the other children that live in the
in the big capitals in the big cities so
this is something that we are giving
back and I can tell you that for example
we just announced this weekend and a new
set of our project where we will provide
over 75% penetration or coverage and of
optical fiber in six very rural
districts around our biggest mountain in
Portugal so our six very rural
municipalities that
this summer we'll have 75 percent of
their population covered with fiber
which is going from almost zero to 100
because it's areas where today the only
access to technologies either copper or
satellite very refreshing to hear it's
critically important I think as we go
forward looking at more broadly or
consumers so not not only the rural was
but your entire consumer food print a
lot of them have had flavor for a while
now do you see any major changes in
consumer behavior where they actually
have fiber available to them this is a
topic that is very close to our heart
and actually tomorrow we will be
launching a new study on the
socio-economic benefits of fiber which
is mostly based on the experience and
Sweden but we would be very interested
in the Portuguese experience as well
well it's true that of course by laying
down fiber and doing this massive
rollout throughout the country that we
have also followed along with the launch
of commercial offers for instance
gigabit connectivity symmetrical
connectivity so all these kind of ultra
broadband connectivity
is now being provided I wouldn't
nevertheless I wouldn't say that the
biggest driver in terms of adoption and
usage patterns it's not just a question
of all you can hit in terms of problems
it's much more than that
first it's also the change in paradigm
of what customers desire we know that
video is the killer app on broadband so
what we see more than just people eating
up one gigabit connectivity is people
changing their habits in towards what it
is the consumption of video a linear
nonlinear over-the-top or not so this is
an example which is not a direct
consequence but it's under echt and we
believe which is a trend to follow also
important is usage patterns and usage
behaviors that go beyond the home we see
more and more in public services in
Portugal like education and health care
those are - with good examples where in
fact the fact that fibre now gets
to all municipalities to all the
countries to those rural municipalities
that I've just described we now have
health centers pharmacies we have basic
schools etc which are now connected with
fiber and this leads to a total
different approach towards public
services so it's true that sometimes we
just associated directly with the retail
market with the residential market but
what we see is that public services are
also tremendously benefiting from this
fiber rollout and most of that that's
where we see the usage pattern changing
because it's totally different for a
school with 200 kids to have a DSL
connection with 2 megabits per second or
having a 1 gigabit connection third and
last but not least it's also Portugal is
an SMB a small and medium business in
the market so what we see as well is
that these very small or micro companies
are also taking a lot of benefit from
low cost broadband connectivity provided
by fiber you talked there about the
different ways of engagement
particularly government agencies etc
let's talk about the the business model
the business case around fiber and
within lt''s Portugal - you have you
found now with your penetration of fiber
increasing across the board that it's
opening up new opportunities to generate
new revenue streams that just simply
wouldn't be possible with the old
mediums well yes first of course as I
told you just before at the SMB the
small and medium businesses is clearly a
way for small companies that before only
had the fiber point-to-point
availability now we jeep on availability
this means creating a more democratic
environment for access to broadband
technologies so this is clearly one on
the retail segment what we are looking
and I won't get into too much details by
obvious reasons but we are looking
towards a total shift in what it is
usage patterns from residential
customers it's not just about the plate
a potato the the one size fits all
that's not what customers want anymore
customers want their size they want
tailor-made solutions and to provide
tailor-made solutions especially looking
at video as the killer app these
means a totally different mindset to
what it is bundling and packaging
services to the home so this is also a
way to monetize fiber and by monetizing
this and bundling this we also put on
the loop different services we are an
aggregator of content by definition so
being an aggregator of content and of
applications of those third parties also
allows us to monetize third and last is
the importance of wholesale as well we
have presented in Portugal last year a
commercial offer for wholesale access to
our fiber so this means that we opened
up to our competitors our fiber on a
jeep on perspective not on an eco
investment model because we do the
investment on ourselves but then on a
wholesale model with an entry fee and
the recurring fee as well
so unfortunately competitors are I would
say resistant to adopt this commercial
offer but it's there for the taking we
have the capacity to do it and I believe
it's also a way to monetize what we have
been doing in the country okay I'll
teach Portugal is probably in somewhat
of a unique position with given the
level of penetration that you have now
you're you're able to reflect with
real-world experience on the differences
in the operational cost between the
traditional copper networks versus the
new fiber networks are there any
findings you can share with us
absolutely the first it's more obvious I
would say is the fact that in terms of
service visits in terms of
disconnections
and voluntary disconnections etc of
course it's obvious that everything that
goes around fibre it's much more
effective and efficient efficient than
what goes around copper so it's true
that in the places where we are doing
this shift from copper to fiber we are
experiencing more savings in terms of
our operations in the field that's
that's obvious for us but it's also
important to reflect that the I would
say the retention of customers customer
loyalty in areas where we are deploying
fiber it's proven and now it's clearly
proven to be much more there's a
stickiness from the customers to our
services on fiber so migration from
copper to fiber is an
experience that we have been doing and
it pays off as well in our perspective
of course then it comes with all our
projects that we have on the engineering
front which is also without creating of
course even because we have rules in the
country that doesn't allow us to
decommission copper unless a certain
amount of rules are obliged for of
course but nevertheless the last
occupancy of the traditional digital
switches etc allows us to gradually
reduce the amount of copper and the
amount of digital switches that we have
in the field and that also brings to us
additional efficiency and cost savings
so on all those perspectives so customer
stickiness of operational efficiency
technological efficiency cost savings in
all those friends it's true that fibre
pays off but again let me just stress
that it's not all about the business
cases I told you there's a social impact
to it that we are also responsible to do
and we are doing it happily to
contribute to the development of our
economy as well know for sure absolutely
and it sounds like it's a collection of
greedy ingredients there's no one silver
bullet the people can look towards truth
very good
coming back a little bit to your
original technology background in
looking a little bit and to the future
what would you expect to be kind of the
the next technology development that
will be deployed the next technology
advancement that will be deployed and
how would you expect those technological
advances to alter or elevate the
end-user experience I do believe that if
we speak purely on technology
perspective we believe that our Jeep on
FTTH and we are doing really FTTH of
fiber-to-the-home in all our deployments
we are talking fiber to the home
directly
we believe that fiber to the home we
jeep on in terms of the fixed industry
that's something that we do believe that
will remain it's an infrastructure that
we are deploying that that will be there
available for the country for the
upcoming years or decades so I would say
that on a technology perspective in
terms of next steps I would
more relevantly the development on
mobile or wireless technologies one of
them is clearly everything that goes
around wireless connectivity at home
customers at home now that they have
ultra broadband both for a reasonable
price they want more and more convenient
services so Wi-Fi ZigBee all those
wireless protocols that flow around the
house to provide convenience on the
usage of the services it's clearly an
area of investment and it's clear an
area that we are very actively looking
at the the other one is of course IOT
and machine to machine with everything
that we have done in infrastructure in
the country we are now able to provide
and we are doing that as well our single
run project our 4G modernization the
launch of 4G plus or 4G advanced that we
have just launched last year as well so
all this brings a brand new world not
only for people but also for connected
devices and connective sensor the
connected sensors so everything that
goes around IOT and machine-to-machine
is an area that we are investing we have
started to deploy our narrowband IOT
network as well throughout the country
and this is an area of focus on a more
applicational front I would say that
artificial intelligence is one of the
areas that we are focusing not that much
on the more I would say the more common
or the the the part of into there
artificial intelligence that people see
more as sci-fi in what it is the touch
points with people we see it more on the
network part on how the interfacial
intelligence can bring again efficiency
and effectiveness to our networks
self-healing mechanisms the way to know
our networks and to balance capacity
depending on usage patterns etc so all
this is an area where we are investing
on Big Data and artificial intelligence
so this would be technology speaking the
the next big trends that we see but
again one of the things it's not
technology but it's also offer its the
commercial offer and as I told you
before it's not one size fits all is
also to be able to adapt technology to
what the customers
and customers want tailor-made solutions
more and more and that's also where we
are focusing great what are the hot
topics am today as it's cropped upward
pretty much every speaker so far um has
been the whole view on 5g and the
assertion that's been made by quite a
few including myself is that 5g goes
hand-in-hand with very deep fiber
penetration and I'd love to hear your
views on that and also to understand
given the level of fiber penetration
that you guys enjoy today how you how
you view out he's Portugal how well
they're positioned to be one of the
forerunners and the 5g deployments in
Europe well we see that as exactly is
the same way as when we build a home
when you build a house first you lay you
need to lay down the grounds and for us
the grounds are there infrastructurally
speaking all our antennas all our towers
ninety-five percent of our mobile sites
are connected with fiber as we speak so
this means that for us the question that
Enrique just spoken just before about
the need to have multiple gigabit
connection to the mobile sides it's it's
something that I do believe it's it's
the right approach and we've been doing
that with our massive rollout of optical
fiber so as I told you 95% of our mobile
stations are connected with fiber so
they are 5g ready in that sense
now the next layer is exactly the kind
of services that we put on top and to
put those services on top of these
infrastructures it's true that we are
still debating a lot in terms of what
will be the killer app what will be the
way to monetize the investment how do we
monetize a new investment where we are
still trying to Omer ties the
investments that we did on 4G and 4G
plus how do we convince users that they
need 5g when we are providing 300 400
megabits connectivity on 4G networks as
well still so I have a lot of doubts in
terms of the rush that people are having
in the in the last sense which is the
roof of the home which is to provide 5g
services we are looking at it we have
labs we are studying we are analyzing
but that's the rooftop so it's the last
thing that we will touch mice the mid
part of of this home it's really is
think that we've already been spoken
here before and it's something where we
are more actively working which is the
the different parody in terms of
technology to support 5g services which
is virtualization so besides having
mobile sites connected with fiber we
need to have all our infrastructures all
our platforms all our applications ready
to sustain the level of connectivity the
level of density the level of throughput
that will be required for 5g so working
on the data center the edge data center
approach working on the virtualization
approach working on changing the
architectures of our systems and our
services this is clearly the the second
layer after the fiber the second layer
where we are working on and then later
on there will be the roof of the home
which will be the services and I'll do
monetize those for sure thank you our
last question today to you we are still
of the quite at the beginning of the
sphere of 2018 14th of February actually
is Roberto viola has pointed out in his
video messages Valentine's Day say so
what would be your top three goals or if
you like top three wishes for 2018 well
I would say that the first first wish
and goal at the first time is that
Altice Portugal remains a market leader
in Portugal remains a leader in all the
segments that we operate where we are
leaders but also that we are able to
grow to grow our customer base to grow
our profitability because it's not
because we are an incumbent that we are
forced to be stuck or even to decline in
terms of market shares we believe that
we can be a modern incumbent we can
continue to lead and we can continue to
grow and that's our goal
the second goal or second wish would be
definitely that we continue to pursue
our innovation front we have our labs in
Portugal for artists group worldwide
these labs are has been tremendously
important in our optical fiber rollout
and we want to continue to invest in
innovation and this investment in
innovation will be
side-by-side with a social investment
that we are doing with our are all our
optical fiber deployment to to give back
to the populations into the economy of
the country what we have been able to
achieve so I would say that goal number
two would be to keep Altis Portugal as
the driving engine for the economy
growth in Portugal but also to to the
growth of the social impact of
technology in people's lives and to
benefit people's lives and to improve
people's lives as well so this would be
goal number two and well goal number
three having in mind that just this last
weekend Portugal has won the European
Championships of indoor soccer having in
mind that two years ago we were the
European Championships of Portugal of
soccer as well and by the way Altice
Portugal is the main sponsor of
Portuguese football
we sponsor not only the national the
male national team but also the female
team also the young teams Beach Soccer
and indoor soccer as well and we are in
the year of the World Cup I would say
that my third wish would be that Ronaldo
and the Portuguese team would be world
champions as well
[Applause]